(telephone dialing)
(telephone ringing)
- [Male] Hello?
- [Narrator] Ah, first crushes,
we all remember them
and if you're a girl
who grew up in the '90s,
your first crush might have been
one of the Dream Phone guys.
- Oh boy, I think Gary.
He has kind of a nice smile.
Yeah, I'd say Matt's probably a jock.
- [Narrator] This is Mike Gray,
the unlikely inventor
of the ultimate '90s tween dating game.
- We knew the game targeted
towards nine-year-old girls.
It was a bunch of guys that did it
but that's okay.
- [Male Voice] I know who
it is but I'm not telling.
- [Mike] I said, let's do
something that's kind of like Clue
so it's deduction,
we're gonna call a bunch of boys
'cause we heard some boy likes us.
- [Interviewer] So it all
started with the phone, right?
- Yes.
We kind of laughed
and we kind of called
this the pink slipper.
In its day, it was an
elegant and beautiful thing.
- [Male] I know where he hangs out.
- [Narrator] So how did they pick the boys
of your teenage dreams?
- [Mike] We went to a photo house.
We didn't know, like, who these
boys were or anything.
We just picked ones that we liked.
- [Narrator] But that's not
the only '90s girls game
Mike made.
He also made the super
successful Mall Madness,
but he's pretty real about
his influence as a guy.
- Well, if I'm gonna make
a game about shopping,
what I know about shopping,
you just go get what you
need and get back to the car.
Later it was pointed out to me
that that's kind of not
the way ladies shop.
So it was kind of in a
funny way a guys game
but it was for girls.
I say games are togetherness in a box.
Play a game with people,
you learn a lot about them
and it shouldn't be
about winning and losing,
it should be about being together.
- [Male] You're right.
(yelling)